رغم الضغوط والانتقادات الدوليه لنظام
الايراني بسبب قمعه الاحتجاجات المندلعه
منذ مقتل مهس امني تدل مؤشرات على قدره
السلطه الايرانيه على رفع وتيره القمع ضد
المتظاهرين خلال الفتره المقبله النظام
الايراني بامكانه ان يزيد من قمع
الاحتجاجات الكلام هنا للباحث في الشؤون
الايرانيه يا غشاغ في مقابله مع صحيفه
الفرنسيه الفرنسيه
اي عام
1978 وحال النظام الايراني حاليا وخلص الى
ان الملل في ايران يمثلون طبقه متماسكه
الى حد ما مضيفا ان الخلافات الداخليه بما
في ذلك في صفوف الحرس الثوري تظهر ان
القمع الشرسه لم يعد بالاجماع لكنه قد
يتطور اكثر
الباحث ذاته يعتبر ما سماها بالثوره في
ايران تجذب كل اولئك الذين يرون ان فساد
قادتهم وعدم كفاءتهم تسبب بالركود والعزله
الدوليه مضيفا ان الامر سيتطلب المزيد
لتغيير النظام لكن في المقابل يمكن ان
يزيد من تكثيف القمع يا غشاغ اضاف ايضا ان
اداء الامريكيين يعزز اكثر النظام
الايراني ويدفعه الى طلب الحمايه الروسيه
خاصه في المجال العسكري ما يجعل المحتجين
يستنكرون هذه التدخلات بالنظر الى التكلفه
الباهظه التي تترتب عنها وفقا الباحث نفسه
بلال العربيه